doctor another point that you hit is
that athletes on the average seem to die
earlier than your average yes Couch
Potato yes our library why yeah why is
that well it's just the opposite what
you think and and it's because people
really don't understand physical um
physiology physical physiology um and
that is this
um with the exception of three black
guys from the old negro baseball league
back in the 1920 there's never been a
professional athlete Liv to be 100 now
that should begin to give you Clues red
flags now these guys are getting paid to
train and work out they're getting the
best food the best trainers personal
Physicians team Physicians I mean they
have it all right they're being paid to
work out and they get the best but yet
the average lifespan when you take all
sports is 62 the new statistics out for
Canadian professional football players
is
51 Reggie Lewis who is the captain of
the Boston Celtics died at 28 of a
cardiopathy heart attack a simple
nutritional
efficiency um let's see here Walter pton
died of 45 waiting for a liver
transplant for from a simple mineral
deficiency disease which I treat all the
time we can reverse that disease in a
few weeks or a few months with a simple
supplement and he died waiting for a
liver transplant and then we just
recently had a 16-year-old boy Wes
Leonard uh from a little high school in
Michigan uh there were two teams
fighting for the last slot in the
playoffs to be the state champions this
just happened a couple months ago and
westlander was 16 years old and the
teams was 5555 with the last buzzer so
they had to do
a prophetic term sudden death playoff
right so he catches the pit the tip off
three or four dribbles down to the
basket slam dunks it in like three
seconds after the whistle to start the
sudden death he gets the winning two
points
5755 his teammates are lifting him up
because they're so excited and he drops
dead of a cardiopathy heart attack the
same thing that Reggie Lewis
did what 17 years earlier and see the
medical system hasn't learned anything
because we eliminated that disease in
children 25 years ago in China in China
these cardiopathy heart disease that
these athletes die from is called kesan
disease is one profin doesn't have the
selenium in the soil there and these
kids like 13 out of a 100 are dying from
this heart disease when they're little
kids so my wife and I went there in
China we did 1,200 autopsies on these
kids when kids under the age of 10 and
the Chinese government now gives every
kid this Trace mineral when they come to
class they haven't lost another kid in
25 years okay because the government
make sure under penalty of severe
punishment if the teacher fails to give
those kids that pill every day
here we have these kids we've known this
in the animal industry for 60 years
Scott for 60 years we've known the cause
prevention cure for this
disease and medical doctors say well we
give them electrocardiograms before each
season we just need more physical
that'll do it well no it won't do it
because they know nothing about
nutrition they don't realize when you
sweat you're not sweating out water you
just drink water you're going to die
whether you're a roofer in the
summertime it's 20° up there on the roof
and you're sweating like a pig or you
unloading trucks or you work in a
factory you're doing physical labor on
the road or you're an athlete if you're
sweating you're not sweating out water
uh sweat is a soup that contains all the
nutrients floating around your blood and
if you're replacing that soup with water
what's happening to your nutritional
reserves replacing the soup with water
your nutritional reserves go down and
when you reach a certain level below a
certain line you die there's another
19-year-old girl just died of um a
copper deficient she's 19 years old
Florida State University died of a
ruptured atic aneurism which is caused
by only one thing well two things one
you get crushed against a loading dock
by a truck or copper deficiency we
learned about that in Turkey Scott 1947
we eliminated ruptured AIC aneurysms in
turkeys in 1947 so she died of something
that a turkey wouldn't even die from
because medical doctors know nothing
about nutrition they all should be put
in jail for
it